je crains qu'elle ne soit pas
suffisamment aguerri et qu'elle n'ait
pas conscience que c'est la forme qui
fera passer le fond
monsieur le premier ministre sheikh jean
merci tout d'abord pour ton engagement
sans faille je pense que nous sommes
également attachés à l'intérêt général à
la cohésion de notre pays à l'égalité
des chances faut pas oublier qu'ils
allaient de borne est ingénieur de
formation et les ingénieurs
intellectualise leur discours ils
utilisent davantage leur hémisphère leur
hémisphère gauche que leur hémisphère
droit donc elles n'échappent pas à cette
règle là la difficulté va être la
communication orale et notamment la
forme puisqu'elle est assez prévisible
dans sa façon de s'exprimer notamment
ses courbes mélodiques sont souvent les
mêmes ce qu'ils peuvent donner un petit
côté on va dire au trimestre au prix
fixe parce que vous privilégiez toujours
un foot industriels qui veut se
moderniser et que vous incarnez ce
qu'est la nouvelle méthode voulue par le
président de la république ce qui me
gêne davantage c'est la rythmicité
belgique parce que là elle est très
prévisible la sécurité ferroviaire c'est
vraiment un sujet avec lequel on peut
pas on peut pas transiger quelqu'un qui
par exemple un trajet entre metz et
verdun dix fois dany retour dix fois par
mois c'est une économie de plus de 29
euros par mois il est clair qu'elle doit
travailler ce côté là qu'elle a soit
davantage ses compétences donc il va
falloir soit travailler
soit resté comme elle est et ça aura un
peu comme edith cresson à l'époque même
si la voile est pas là mais nous avait
d'abord on a une fois aux graves qui
créent sont plus intéressants que je
dirais intrinsèquement
mais ça risque de lui poser des
problèmes
comme ça apposait déplacement il ya un
poids quand même positif c'est que elle
n'a pas cette propension à donner de
l'intensité et donc sa voix le monde par
hbo vous privilégiez toujours le
collectif et que vous incarnez ce qu'est
un ministre ce qu'est un premier
ministre c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui sert
son pays donc merci très sincèrement il
brave ou alors comme vous l'imaginez jeu
je suis évidemment très ému ce soir et
je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une
pensée pour la première femme qui a
occupé ses fonctions
edith cresson et peut-être je voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves et rien ne doit
freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société
et c'est plutôt intéressant parce
qu'elle va donner une image de quelqu'un
qui est pondéré
et qui a deux qui a de la six donc ça
peut contribuer à montrer de la
confiance et ça peut déstabiliser des
interlocuteurs
c'est intéressant de penser qu' on
pourrait la rapprocher dans gala merkel
n'est pas la reine de la prosodie enfin
c'est à dire qu'elle était qu'elles
déplaçaient des foules quand s exprimer
mais en revanche on l'écoutait je pense
qu'elles ''s'en osborne à ce avoir cette
qualité là sans eau calme que n'oublions
pas où la voûte dans les dernières
élections présidentielles que la forme
est d'une importance capitale la
communication orale on voit avec
mélenchon on voit pour voiles et ça a
joué aussi un mauvais tour pour yannick
jadot par exemple pour hidalgo donc
c'est d'une importance capitale en
france et donc si elle s'inspire si elle
a un côté angela merkel elle devra de
toute façon en robes et ses discours un
peu un peu plus
[Musique]